as a Universalist then you are certainly
looking for the one principle
that is redeployed at successive scales
yeah and that should be a sufficient
explanation for those things that
emergent behaviors at particular scales
so I think that that is absolutely true
and again you can read this from the
point of view of a mathematician from
the point of view of renormalization
group and what does that mean what it
just means that if I take lots and lots
of little things and I start coarse
grading them in a particular way then if
I want to describe the behavior of all
the elements at one scale of
organization say molecules or cells or
people then if I can write then down
their Dynamics in terms of say
lagrangians some way of summarizing
their Dynamics and all the things that a
company or ensue from this that Dynamics
then if I do my core screening and then
look at the collective the average
Behavior